[Musique]
les enfants nous sommes arrivés le north
on est fin pas trop mais je ne vois pas
juliette à peine n'est pas venu me
chercher ce soir qui ne va pas te perdre
j'espère moi non mon instinct guide ne
mets pas mon seul
jt
alors sur la terre je suis bien profond
de voreppe gens
qui côtoient gaga c'est même un bel et
bien moi aussi je me lave toujours les
dans l'hygiène c'est la santé
on a frappé
si on frappe à la porte c'est que l'on
désire entrer en très bon soir mes amis
bonsoir ferme north
juillet temps je ne les ai pas vus elle
n'est pas venue me chercher
elle est allée dans la forêt oui
sûrement je vais la chercher
juillet de
6 le roi m'avait donné
paris saran vivre
qu'il eût fallu quitter
lamour dom amis à
redire et on en
rit
ronronner beaupré paris
noms mais on connaît leur web à côté oui
on chante je vous écoute les amis
[Musique]
le pourquoi d'un copain un fils à qui le
talonnait le grand sept lots à l'unisson
nous rend votre majesté emma culotté
gevrey lui dit normand
colons 3
comme l a fait un gros sabres dû faire
le grand saut des lois le dit on au roi
votre majesté pour un seul blessé
gevrey lui dit le roi je me donne un
sabre de poids
la colère des voiliers en hiver le
concept des lois le nid au moment notre
main juste m as far as geler ce vrai lui
dit le roi et tu peux souffler sur tes
droits les parois dagobert
chasser dans la plaine donnèrent le
grand saint-eloi le kit for war iii
geste est bien née souffle et se voit
lui dit le roi à lapins courait après
moi
même et non pas requis sur la maine le
grand show des lois ni comment votre
main juste stéphanois y est ce vrai lui
dit leur mort
pourra crier leroy plat
allons veux tu rentrais vadrouille ou
jacky
allons au dodo juliette à vous aussi les
enfants moi je vais tout de suite j'aime
bien faire de beaux rêves
comment sont ils heureux
twitter
est bien fait de beaux rêves et vous
aussi les enfants
bonne nuit
[Musique]
le la nuit apporte calme et repos chers
amis
[Musique]
aux
patrons
patrons qui attisent nord si l'on a de
la veine cornichons il fait des rêves en
couleur moi je ne rêve conte noir et
blanc aux pauvres nous
allons en rut venir les enfants et fêtes
de bourg
en couleurs
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
vous
[Musique]